hello everyone my name is Ben and I've
lost my voice I know it's very careless
of me I'm usually a better person than
this but as the old saying goes The Show
Must Go On so without further Ado let's
get going oh and I'm very happy to take
questions at any time during the talk
feel free to make this as interactive as
you like but be aware that the answer
you receive was written this morning at
1am if it sounds relevant to your
question I assure you it's entirely
coincidental okay JWT what is it good
for absolutely everything
almost
in this session I want to take you back
to a time when online life was scary if
only we knew it at the time let's go on
a journey turn right in 300 meters no
not that kind of Journey sorry about
that
who remembers seeing one of these
screens this is Friend Finder and a
variety of implementations could be
found on any number of social media
sites in the early 2000s in order to
quickly and painlessly invite your
friends to the platform it was an
ingenious idea because there's no point
in having a social network with just a
handful of users I see a number of you
looking amused and you probably know
where I'm going next at least one of you
is crying now and I don't think it's
happy tears if we look at this form
you'll notice that Facebook is asking
for their email address and the password
they log into their email service with
see I told you life was scary back then
but wait there's more let's dive into
one possible implementation to see how
much scarier this actually was and
please note that I'm not picking on
Facebook particularly most social
networks did this and it was a very bad
idea
so let's start with the user on the left
and The Social Network web server on the
right to kick the process off the user
sends their email address and email
password to the server next the server
will make a direct connection to the
email provider but not to an API it will
pretend to be a human user of a web
browser and dynamically screen scrape
the data that's right the social network
was now logged in as the user and had
full access to everything contacts
emails the lot after Gathering all the
contact details The Social Network would
store these in their own database in
order to then send out emails to each
contact inviting them to join the
network but wait how would they send
these emails I hear you ask through the
user's email provider of course why
would you add complexity of sending
emails from your system which would
appear to come from your product when
you can send an email by screen scraping
your way into the compose view in the
user's email provider and send the email
directly from that user psychologically
people would be more likely to join a
platform that their friends personally
invited them to then if they got a
generic email from the platform itself
and then to top it all off in all
likelihood The Social Network would also
store each contact in their own database
as a ghost user from the offset this
allows them to start building a vague
profile of each person immediately even
if they don't sign up until years later
what could go wrong and of course this
is all very questionable whether it's
okay to store information about someone
who hasn't yet signed up for your
services but let's remind ourselves of
the real WTF the user has to share their
email credentials for this to work
so I'm able to turn a microphone on
every now and then and as you can tell
my voice really is buttered with you I
wish this was because I had a good time
a few days ago unfortunately that's not
the reason um I'd like to take a brief
pause to thank Phil for Lending me his
laptop which is currently outputting
this audio and then as you may notice
his phone is also connected to his
laptop so if we get any calls I will try
and answer them and can all speak up
when that happens
I don't know maybe we can Rick Roll some
of the Dinos
oval 2.0 to the rescue this
authorization protocol was designed to
remove the need to share credentials and
also added in constraints or scopes of
operations that could be performed once
a system had been authorized let's see
how that works
rather than sending credentials to The
Social Network the user scarves the
Friend Finder process with a simple
request the server responds with a
redirect to the email provider which the
user can then log into the email
provider will then generate a token for
the user which is limited to the scope
on for example reading the user's
contact list and the user can then pass
that token to The Social Network finally
The Social Network server can request a
contact list from the email providers
API using the token to verify that
access has been granted and the email
provider can return the contact list as
for sending emails that was always
something The Social Network should have
sorted themselves and we can't stop them
from creating those dodgy ghost accounts
either
because I'm lagging a little bit
so some examples of what an oval 2.0
authorization might allow LinkedIn can
read emails on Gmail tweetdeck can post
tweets on Twitter Eventbrite can create
events on Facebook but how can we get
identity information from another
provider I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I
can't do that
this led to most large sites
implementing their own way of doing this
allowing someone to log into a website
with Google for example would be hugely
valuable to Google while making it
easier for users who didn't have to go
through the process of creating a new
account
so as you can see we're at a process now
we're at a point now where there's
obviously a desire for identity to be
something that we can pass between
entities in a secure way without having
to share credentials with those systems
as well and we're very early on in the
process here where sister large
organizations like Google and Facebook
and Myspace anybody still have a MySpace
account
just me okay
um they they wanted to be able to
provide uh facilities for their users to
be able to log into third-party systems
and I or rather Daniel if have American
you say that's Daniel everybody Daniel
Daniel everybody
um I don't know what was talking about
that seems really weird I was talking
about how Google benefits from this and
one of the ways that these organizations
would benefit from it is that they would
become seen as a a safe space to be to
have an identity and people would sign
up for a Google account because they
would log into another system and after
having done it once they could to
multiple places
that have benefit to the user is they
don't have to remember I mean we
shouldn't be remembering passwords
anyway everybody uses a passport manager
right
three of you
I'm worried for I'm worried for Humanity
um yeah so we came up with this user
info
um process but it was so new as with
anything when whenever four or five
large organizations want to do something
look at it nowadays with um apis within
browsers the kind of things that
um people are playing with by completing
Edge apis that are just coming in
they're all implemented differently
they're totally incompatible with each
other and they have to then work
together to build something that's more
compatible
so I heard of that in because I think I
skipped a little bit uh in the text part
in much the same way as I wrote 2.0
could be used to get contact details a
token could allow the retrieval of
information about the user as with all
new ideas each provider implemented it
differently returning different response
formats
open ID connect was ratified to
standardize a way to retrieve the data
and the format that should be expected
and it was really simple we like simple
it's basically a simple identity layer
that sits on top of oauth 2.0 will
actually verify the identity obtain
basic profile information from the
provider is rest based so we know how to
make the request in every situation and
returns Json a flexible extensible but
predictable data structure
I realized how good it was to be able to
drink while you're giving a talk
there's coffee right away it'll be here
later
and that brings us to JW please all
Jason Webb tokens
this is what they look like any
questions
thanks for coming everybody it's been
great
okay let's dig in if we look closely we
will see three parts separated by full
stops these are the header the payload
and the signature the first two are base
64 URL encoded Json which we can easily
decode a typical identity token might
have a header and payload like this note
that they aren't encrypted just encode
it so you shouldn't be storing sensitive
data in there in the payload we'll see
certainties like SUV which stands for
subject and AIT which is the issue that
time stamp for the token it's best not
to use these for another purpose but
being Jason you can add any arbitrary
data in that you want
he use things in situations that are
given your reaction that we should
probably should not see the light of day
has anybody ever played on Jason Webb
tokens before is this brand new to
anybody
brand new to a couple of you yeah so
there's always been this debate about
how secure are they
um like I mentioned they're not
encrypted you can get encrypted Json web
tokens
um but yeah by and large you should just
treat them as information that gets sent
around but it's totally readable by
anybody uh if you're really clever you
could probably decode that in your head
I certainly can't probably most of us
can't
um but yeah I mean people can look at
this and go oh that's cool I can send
that and nobody can read it but it's
actually just basically break break the
animal
I think that's weird into readable text
what is called a confirmation break
Hannibal is in the dictionary thanks
and to create the signature in this
example baseball in a synchronous H Mac
256 algorithm we take the base64 URL
encoded header and payload and user
pre-shared key any system can regenerate
the signature in the future to compare
with the signature in the token in order
to verify the header and payload have
not been altered up to the Token was
issued and best of all the receiving
party can verify the token and rely on
the payload without having to
communicate with the issuer
so just as an aside if you want to see
the script of this and the words I had
to write for it to be able to pronounce
the words properly and it still gets it
wrong come chat to me afterwards and let
me show you
there's another GWT the access token
that contains different information in
the payload here you can see the issuer
the subject the audience that is
permitted to consume the token and at
the bottom the scope in this example the
bearer of this access token could send a
message to the example API to post a new
article but presumably not delete
anything
now that you have a better understanding
of what jwts are how they can relate to
authorization and identity and what
protections they contain that make them
trustable let's have a look at a couple
of scenarios in which this can be useful
this one looks like a plate of spaghetti
but if you look at the two Orange Lines
they are the only Communications that
include user credentials when logging in
from the web browser or a mobile app the
user authenticates themselves to the
identity provider which returns tokens
that can be used for all future requests
the mobile device can make authorized
requests to the API the web server can
retrieve resources from the web server
the database can use the identity token
to filter results or determine the right
to update entries and even the active
directory server on the right can join
the party by providing single sign-on to
all users without the applications
needing to communicate with it at all
directory
either or not admitting to it because
you have pains that you don't want to
discuss or you have not experienced the
pain so please don't go there
but perhaps more interestingly we can
augment token payloads to allow business
logic to act more intelligently or even
to eliminate certain infrastructure
altogether here we see a hypothetical
react app that renders a web store based
on product data in stripe which should
retrieved using metlify functions but we
need some way of connecting stripe
customers to all zero users usually we'd
Implement a custom database for this in
this scenario we're going to store this
information in auth zero and stripe when
a user logs in auth0 will make sure a
striped customer exists for them and if
not we'll create one stride will be
given the auth zero user ID and will
return the new stripe customer ID which
will be stored against the auth 0 user
giving us a bi-directional connection
between two entities on separate systems
next we'll return the token to the react
app right after we add the stripe
customer ID to the payload now the react
app can call netlify function functions
that proxy through to Stripes API and
knowing the striped customer ID all
orders are correctly hooked up and
associated with the currently logged in
user
each situation you face will require
specific consideration of the pros and
cons of each design choice but this
setup could potentially be ready for
production for lower traffic websites
and scaling could be achieved through
caching and the use of content delivery
networks before a custom database needs
to be considered it's a great example of
the ability we have nowadays to rapidly
build and deploy near production-ready
applications in hours or days instead of
the weeks and months of yesteryear
all right let me try and use my voice a
little I worked out that if I try and
relax my vocal cords I can actually
reject a little bit more but the problem
is I get excited about what I'm talking
about my whole body tenses up and then
this happens and I can't talk probably
so normally when I get this talk
um it's a lot more interactive so this
is actually like pretty much the end
um because when you script a talk you
can't anticipate what kind of question
I want to try and use my voice as much
as is possible at inside
you do have so it's coming again already
um but uh one thing I do want to point
out is that actually I'm just gonna
ignore the speaking dude he's got a
couple more things to say here they're
not important
I thought I can't see them myself
so the workshop that I mentioned is
actually available on GitHub if you want
to play with it it's self-guided you can
do it yourself you might even find a
video out there of me giving that
um bad Workshop and one thing I wanted
to get out of that it'll take probably
about
three four hours roughly um don't have
to do anyone go it's broken down into
steps but it'll take you through various
things it'll actually help you set up
the react app get off zero configured
get stripe configured and um you
basically end up with a functioning web
app that you could like a web store that
you could potentially put into
production I'm not going to say it's 100
production ready I haven't tested it
I'll leave it to you to decide whether
or not that's something you want to do
um but it's a really good way of playing
with uh new ways and thinking outside of
the box we've development one of the
things that I like about Json tokens
they encapsulate this information
allows you to communicate more than just
like
like an opaque token the old tokens that
we're used to that have no data inside
them or no readable data you can't do
anything with them other than go to the
Azure and say what does this allow me to
do
by using a Json web token you can expand
through that flexibility of the payload
um but any information you want in there
bearing in mind for more information
about
the bigger payload the bigger the token
and that token goes in the header
request of every the header of every
request and you don't want to be in a
situation where your requests are so big
that you've got latency and scalability
issues so bear that in mind as well but
JJ would use to give you a lot of scope
for playing in ways that would normally
not be possible to do
the Yep this one without a custom
database would be extremely hard if it
were not for the functionality with jwts
Breakers so they're really simple really
small really almost overlookable
technology
um but the things that you could do with
them are so varied and um
uh interesting I guess in certain ways
so if you have the time I would highly
recommend that home button that you at
the very least have a look at the repo
this is basically like the readme is the
instructions for how to get through it
and just get an idea of what kind of
things you can do in that situation and
maybe that'll then give you a different
perspective of how you can use them in
in your applications and in your systems
at work or other work as well
so I will take questions I think that
microphone there might be some people at
home can hear you
they can hear me and hopefully if you
have questions that I will have the
vocal stamina to give you a response but
aside from that um thank you for
sticking around forward it's a very
short presentation but hopefully the
value has been shown and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the the conference
thank
foreign
people coming up to me saying I'm not
going to talk to you because I don't
want you to ruin your voice my only talk
is now given feel free to ruin my voice
it's good
well in which case let's uh get some of
our time back and go back outside and
mingle with his courses thank you